pegi 18
[Musique]
arrête ça sert à rien agnès
l'abeille de l'une des plus grosses
opérations de toute la guerre iraniens à
l'égard
c'est l'occasion de quitter la normandie
sera bassam
il concentre sur tes hommes car ce sont
eux qui font le boulot
sûr parce que rhin avec le pouvoir sera
au coeur de l'allemagne
bon avec moi
nous pensions être prêt pour la guerre
mais rien ne pouvait nous préparer à ça
ps et bio j'étais blacks
j'étais chargé juifs
bio
[Musique]
je n'abandonnerai pas mon escouade on
n'est que des rois joseph si on fait ce
qu'on veut la machine serait peut-être
que vous l'aviez oublié ce sont nos âmes
nous sommes vous oubliez ça prenons ce
pont et sauvons notre camarade
prenez vos armes au liban tu penses
avoir des tribuns
cette date
l'afficheur ce sera tout ou rien c'est
le moment de vérité
diva
abbas alors fritz